[Music]
it's custom-made 70 new - Carly well she
said I wanted to dip like air and I feel
like I'm walking on air sure it is
something that there's so many people
working on it and with such talented
hand they're artists it's a work of art
you know that's why I love fashion
because it is essentially art you look
at these times and what's going on and
you play a woman who helped change the
course of history and now you look at
our history and tell me about that
rhythm they they changed the
Constitution for the better you know and
that's what they're about they're about
equal rights for all that's what we
should all be about what does it mean to
be here today
this in the middle of this madness to be
a nominated woman for such an important
role when I see my name amongst the
other nominees I just feel so thrilled
because I've been there's such amazing
women actresses humble so talented it's
seeping up their pores and I feel very
privileged genuinely but insider your
little giddy - are you a little like oh
my I've got butterflies yeah
[Music]